all right let's go to 7 1 8 let's go to
our caller from the 7 1 8 area code say
hello tell us who you are and what's on
your mind today
oh yes hi my name is Aaron are you doing
your good go ahead and hi I'm just
calling out a question just about just
some of the coverage in the news in
regards to you know the you know the
Russian Russia gate story uh-huh you
know how much coverage we're having and
you know some of the issues were having
in the country so you know was you know
Flint Michigan and you know needs ACOTA
access pipeline and you know how much
coverage that's getting so I just
wondering if you feel like we're getting
too much coverage for Russia I think
that I think that Russia should be
covered fully the problem is with the
24-hour news channels there's plenty of
other hours during which all the topics
you're mentioning should be covered and
I think that gen briny from
congressional dispatch cast would agree
that legislative issues aren't covered
enough and where our money goes isn't
covered enough environmental activists
would feel that you the fact that we
have this sort of crisis of climate
change isn't being covered enough so I
think that it's perfectly it's a really
good critique of corporate media to say
that when you've got 24 hours rather
than recycling the same stories when
there's often no news other stuff should
be covered I'm not ready to say we
shouldn't be talking about Russia that's
sort of what Fox News is doing and we
see how informed their audience is so I
think the caller has generally a good
critique here absolutely yeah
are you concerned like Aaron is there a
particular network you're worried about
here mostly about you know like the you
know you said the the corporate media
yeah and even some even some independent
media kind of seems to go in that
direction a little bit to kind of I
wouldn't say parroting corporate media
but kind of almost kind of becoming a
light version of it in a sense what the
amount of coverage to Russia
like what shows are you thinking of
I mean I would want to go in specific
well I mean nobody knows who they are
you know you're just Aaron right from 7
1 8 no but you could say and what like
are there what I'm curious what shows
you think could fall into that I would
say like maybe like like key Y key for
instance to me I seemed it seems like
they covered that a lot kind of like
almost like an NBC like light and that's
interesting um sort of like I just feel
like after the election their covers
change to a certain degree intra now
they're kind of covering almost like
MSNBC light in a sense got it's just my
opinion but uh are there are there any
independent shows Aaron that you think
have a good balance of Russia coverage I
would say you know like Calculon key
your show I like your show - all right
Jimmy Dore interesting so so two of the
three you mentioned are more or less
critics of coverage of Russia and you
like their balance I think that that's
interesting
yes I like their balance that yeah I
think they you know they see it's good
to have a count about two sides it's not
an easy issue you know that's the tackle
you know so I always hearing both sides
and you know that's you know that's why
I appreciate corker I mean it's our
independent media okay I appreciate it a
lot
all right Aaron point taken and well
made I I appreciate the call and
certainly you know it's good to have
options in the media landscape I think
would be sort of my overall assessment
there